bienvenue à cet hiver en ligne r en 50
ans d'activités liées au vitrail
jamboree est un artiste exigeant il est
intervenu sur les plus beaux vitraux de
france pour restaurer et créer fils et
petit fils de maître verrier c'est une
véritable histoire de transmission ou la
couleur et la lumière sur les maîtres
mots que je vous invite à découvrir
bonjour jean bonjour bonjour alors je
vous salue comme on fait dans les arts
martiaux parce que 50 ans maître verrier
vous êtes carrément ceinture noire en
vitraux mais on a un peu plus de 50 ans
soit ça que 52 ans 8 50 dollars je vous
salue à nouveau mais comment est venu à
vous l'opportunité de réaliser ses
vitraux ont c'est très simple il y avait
des ouvertures béantes se fa clp y avait
rien du tout et c'est moi qui ai proposé
à la formule de faire des petits vitraux
donc je les ai fait gracieusement à
l'accord on va écouter moi j'ai la
village qui s'appelle parler comme on
est pareils l'église à des petits trous
dans les niveaux des murs il ya moyen de
négocier gracieusement également des
vitraux de gens nos rêves a
gracieusement je le fais bien pour ma
commune mais peut-être pas pour tous les
villages de france j'aurais essayé
direction le jardin et l'atelier elle
c'est parti
vous avez ici
une cinquantaine d'années la maison
était déjà dans cet état là ou non non
pas du tout c'était en 1969 je sortais
mon service militaire et je cherchais un
lieu pour me poser pour avoir un atelier
et avec mon épouse on est arrivé un peu
par hasard dans cette cour et
pour cette maison le fameux jardin c'est
magnifique havre de paix comme ont dit
un oui mais le havre de paix il se
mérite aussi
et vous le travail sur le vitrail cette
passion ce coup de foudre qui tend quand
même une transmission familiale ça
commence à l'âge de 3-4 ans quand vous
allez dans l'atelier de votre papa et
c'est peut-être là que se sont produits
un peu les premiers rencontrent les
premiers échanges avec la matière je
pense que c'est la base de ça a été une
base inconsciente de ma réflexion
aujourd'hui c'est pas d'aujourd'hui et
il ya 50 ans est-ce qu'on évoque quand
même votre médaille d'or aux jeux
olympiques de javelot en bois j'ai vu un
javelot à l'entrée faut vous montre ça
c'est incroyable du javelot
regardez-moi ça t'arrive comme ça vingt
deux films le linge et sont là hop au
revoir
la tunisie joue enfin la touche
un des ateliers
c'est quoi donc que ces petits morceaux
de verre là alors ça ce sont des chutes
de mes deux modes de mes travaux
successifs j'en ai des boîtes un peu
partout mais je les conserve et en même
temps c'est l'emplacement de mes petits
enfants les plus jeunes pousses qu'il y
en a qui sont très grands régulièrement
celle de trois ans par exemple
elle est venue ya pas longtemps et elle
fouille
est alors regardez alcrer finalement les
gestes comment je pouvais faire quand
j'avais le dommage qu'elle a hérité des
coupes dont elle se coupe pas non plus
au nord donc moyenne phrase aussi qui
m'a interpellé s'est retranché plutôt
d'ajouter c'est ce que j'essaye de faire
dans mon travail de député même si oui
apparemment envoyé mon atelier n'est pas
épuré mais c'est un atelier truc ça va
te lis dans l'atelier mais dans ma tête
dans ma tête j'ai z aller aussi à
l'essentiel par des gestes simples sûres
de la couleur donc de créer des rapports
particuliers qui vont provoquer les
émotions chez les regardeurs et bien
jean merci 20 ans jean maître jean
maître verrier parce que moi moi moi
qu'il ya des inversions vous êtes
ceinture noire 2e dan de wervicq voilà
au revoir la halle et tchèques ça mon
frère
mais partie